the jury has decided alex jones must pay
more than 4.1 million dollars in his
ongoing defamation damages trial the
reason i say it's a defamation damages
trial is because alex jones never
actually got a real jury trial he was
found in default according to the judge
to the court he did not comply with
discovery according to jones himself he
did
so this is a particularly interesting
case they considered a rare ruling that
a judge just simply said now you lose
moving on and now the jury says 4.1
million which is also interesting
because
you know as much as it's bad for alex
jones i mean the dude is very very
wealthy you can probably easily pay that
but the big news comes tomorrow when
they assess punitive damages
i heard a lot some people are saying can
be upwards of nine million dollars 8.8
or something like that
other people have said four we will see
tomorrow but there's a lot we need to
break down with this case and it is very
interesting and the other big news
joe biden has declared a monkey pox
health emergency
okay
this one's gonna get nasty i'm sorry
just
you just just be prepared we're gonna be
talking about the news we're gonna do
our best to keep things you know family
friendly but this is a really really
insane story what's going on with monkey
pox in this country i'm sure most of you
know so we'll get into that before we
get started my friends head over to
timcast.com become a member if you'd
like to support our work and you'll get
access to the exclusive tim cast
uncensored after hours show we'll have
that up at 11 p.m
plus we've got a bunch of other shows
like tails from the universe world and
uh the big news of course many of you
know this we have since
no we we no longer accept paypal when
doing transactions for members we use
parallel economy a company co-founded by
dan bongino it is censorship resistant
so supporting us is also supporting them
because we need to get more companies
involved with parallel economy.com
using them for for financial
transactions so we can build up an
ecosystem that is resistant to
censorship
joining us uh oh so also yes smash the
like button subscribe to this channel
share the show and joining us to talk
about this case with alex jones which
will be interesting because uh this good
sir it's a lawyer is james lawrence hey
great to be here thank you for having me
do you want to give people a little bit
of information about uh who you are and
you know you were you were in the news
recently sure so i am a lawyer at
envisage law in raleigh north carolina
been practicing there since i left the
trump administration in january of 2021
i had the opportunity to serve in the
department of health and human services
and the immediate office of general
counsel
and was outgoing chief counsel of the
food and drug administration the fda
under uh president trump yep and then
you recently um you're actually involved
in a bunch of lawsuits pertaining to vax
mandates and
and also you uh you were representing
alex berenson in the twitter lawsuit
that's right i was lead counsel for alex
in his lawsuit against twitter which uh
recently settled
right on well we'll talk about all that
we also have mary morgan of pop culture
crisis hello i'm happy to be back
everyone uh my name's mary i co-host pop
culture crisis on youtube it's a daily
live show where we talk about
entertainment news and celebrity drama
and movies all that good stuff go over
and subscribe what's up everybody ian
crossland here from ian crossland.net
i'm very happy to be here nick koenig
super chat my favorite skyrim character
is a rogue that dual wields daggers just
get that out of the way in case really
super chat for now it is i like to play
on legendary difficulty with uh with
like um sneak attack survival mode so
there's no
there's no fast travel yeah and it's
really hard it's like fighting one guy
becomes yeah sneak attack so he played
the vr skyrim negative so much fun it
looks good yeah the bow and arrow i see
people like you can grab npcs and bend
their head and stuff like it's getting
crazy dude yeah right on and lydia of
course on vacation so uh chris is here
handling the show hey what's up everyone
all right let's jump into that first
story from law and crime
texas jury finds alex jones must pay
more than 4.1 million dollars to sandy
hook victim's parents for calling the
massacre a giant hoax this story is
absolutely insane
first they say this is far lower than
the figure parents had asked them to
award 150 million dollars in damages
which their lawyer found a fitting
penalty for jones's decade of deceit
december will mark the 10th anniversary
of the massacre the jury which reached
the verdict on the first day of
deliberations has yet to award punitive
damages and will return on friday to
consider that unresolved matter
only the size of the award has been an
issue at trial as the judge issued a
rare default judgment against jones
before trial for failing to comply with
his discovery obligations
that's not that's weird right you're a
lawyer yeah it is it's not something you
see
a lot in litigation typically if there
are disputes between parties on
discovery so for example if
a plaintiff or a defendant
is seeking documents or answers to
interrogatories or other questions and
discovery there's a process that you go
through right the
council for both parties confer with one
another they try to understand what the
disputes are
and
ultimately
the parties go to the court and ask the
judge to weigh in on
whether or not to order the party to
produce those documents
and i'm not familiar with the specific
details of alex's case in the
procedural history of
how the default judgment happened but it
is a rare thing for a court
to
not
provide any sort of intermediary
just went sanction
to default default less than default
which would be
uh negative inferences perhaps from an
evidentiary standpoint or other
sanctions that the court might levy but
not uh going straight to a finding of
liability do you think
do you think alex jones can can
appeal this and and potentially
win
potentially there's a ground for appeal
for sure if
again and not knowing what the texas
state court precedents are
uh
right now but
they're in theory yes would be a a a
basis to appeal
the finding of of liability which is the
threshold finding for uh the damages
that flowed out today in the 4 million
or so verdict so this is the story from
npr conspiracy theorist alex jones ruled
liable in sandy hook defamation case
this is from november 15 2021
they said a monday ruling from a
connecticut court which found jones and
other defendants liable for defamation
brought swift reaction from an attorney
or any of the families
superior court judge barbara bella cited
the defendant's willful non-compliance
the discovery process as the reasoning
behind the ruling bellas noted that the
defendants failed to turn over financial
and analytics data that were requested
multiple times by the sandy hook family
plaintiffs now this is a connecticut
court
the the the story about the four million
dollars is a texas court i know that
he's got other uh defamation cases
coming from these parents but um the
reason i bring up that story i i believe
it's it's the same one but um
i'm not entirely sure what i know is
that or what i can say
alex told me they complied with
everything but no matter what they gave
they were told they weren't complying
i'm not saying you need to believe alex
jones i'm just saying that's what he's
asserting now the question i have is
if a court orders you to hand something
over that you don't have
and then issues a ruling in default like
what do you do
let's let's operate from the assumption
that alex jones did comply with
discovery as he claims
and they rule in default anyway what do
you do
oh you go to the court and you explain
all the things that you did to
to to produce documents oh yeah you you
try to uh create uh
you you show the court
for example if you're searching for
documents across a corporation for
example what search terms you used how
you
searched for documents how you collected
them and ultimately produced them
you know you you offer the opportunity
for somebody to come and do a forensic
analysis
uh to to make sure you're not hiding
something right those those are the
steps that you could go through to
sort of prove your your uh that you've
you've complied with your obligations
but that
doesn't sound like that opportunity was
provided in this particular case yeah
which again is going to potentially
raise
uh
appealable issues so i wonder if this is
just political
you know four million dollars i'm just
gonna come out and say it for alex jones
he said in trial something like anything
more than two million would like damage
the company or something
i don't believe it
i think i think a four million dollar
ruling alex probably left got in his car
and then went yes
because like a lot of people are posting
on twitter that this may this may as
well have been a victory for for alex
four million dollars because he he he
makes so much money
now he doesn't make as much money as he
used to which is another big element of
this of this trial of this case is that
they're trying to claim
people are just it's so frustrating
dealing with you know
people are saying in the trial they said
alex jones made 165 million dollars in
sales wow alex jones made 165 million
dollars no
that's that's that's gross what's the
net what's the what's the profit what's
the take home what after taxes like how
much money does men actually have
a lot that's why i'm saying like yeah
four million sucks but for someone as
well off as alex as big as his empire is
he could probably pay that how long do
they take to pay that do they give him
like a year every night does he have to
make payments is it a big deal
people don't know anything about this
stuff he's probably never going to pay
him
like there was a there was a viral post
there was not or there was a post on
reddit and then they were like i think
it was related to o.j simpson they said
you know it was a 30 million dollar
wrongful death lawsuit he's only paid
like 100 grand after like 30 years why
because you can't squeeze blood out of a
turnip oh like
what are you gonna do yeah and people
arrange their assets in ways that can
be advantageous in that regard i think
the enron executives right and when in
in the 2000s who had multi-million
dollar verdicts that were levity against
them who bought large houses in
in florida if i'm not uh mistaken or if
i'm remembering correctly because
essentially they could put up put their
assets into a home that couldn't be
levitating against to uh to collect
against the judgment yeah they can't
take your house from you can they or it
depends on what state you're in in terms
of how
uh how far a judgment creditor can go to
collect against you like i said i think
in the case of the enron executives
there are special rules in florida that
that that allow people to put their
assets weren't they like homes weren't
they like buying like a 100 million
dollar house and then being like sorry
i'm in bankruptcy
i i i don't know remember if it was it
was it was that much but it was big
houses big big houses and lots of money
and then when they start like a bunch of
like home renovations they just start
the renovations and they're like sorry
all the money's out even though it
hasn't been built yet yeah it's i don't
know it's easier than that i mean here's
here's one thing you could do right
let's say you uh want to engage in
corrupt behavior or let's say you have
plans to be corrupt and you know
that you can't take the money from an
organization say like i don't know um
you're an elected official
and you want people to pay you for
favors so
um you'll create something called like a
global foundation
and then as let's just say your
secretary of state or something like
that under obama under obama yeah and
then and then all of a sudden hundreds
of millions of dollars are pouring into
your foundation which is unrelated to
you right you know that's one way or or
let's say um
you uh want to do large private equity
deals with china but you are an elected
official so you have your son
fly on the government plane with you
just hypothetically of course and then
um share bank accounts with them even
though i have no idea how how that works
legally but share phone numbers that way
if you were the one communicating you
can always just say it was your kid and
that way
you know you can try and cover it up
those are things you that somebody might
do actually just for the sake of clarity
i'm literally referencing
what joe biden and hillary clinton have
been accused of doing in no way trying
to encourage people to engage in any of
those behaviors right the clinton
foundation right took a lot of money and
then when she was when she lost all of a
sudden the clinton foundation stopped
getting like money just dried up and
just and then they they disbanded it and
now it's back is that yeah they were
like hey we're gonna win again or
something like that when you said that
they one thing alex or someone that
feels like they've been wronged by the
process can go to the court and see if
they can rectify like discovery or
whatever is the court just basically the
judge in this it is the judge you're
right right so you if you have a
discovery dispute
you try to work it out with the other
party first you do something called beat
and confer with the other side to see if
you can resolve the dispute without
having to get the judge involved but
ultimately if you're unsatisfied with
what the other side is doing in terms of
the documents that they've given or the
answers they've given discovery
you go to the court and you move to
compel and you ask the judge to order
them to
order them to uh
to uh provide
responsive documents or answers but what
if you don't have it like
what are you supposed to do there's
nothing yeah anything you can do there
is nothing you can do other than other
than again what i said earlier which is
show
the court the efforts that you've
undertaken to
the judge
the curtain the judge can just be like
ah you're lying
potentially yeah
yeah i think people need to realize
everybody thinks you live in this world
of laws and that the laws dictate what
will happen they don't they're more like
guidelines i think it's funny when
people say you know because carrie lake
is big in the news and they're talking
about her election there was a funny
article that said if carrie alike gets
her legally impossible wish donald trump
will be ineligible to run for president
because you can only win twice or
whatever and i was like legally
impossible i like how they say that as
if like the declaration of independence
was legal as it pertained to the british
parliament like no a bunch of guys drank
and then said you know what we're
declaring independence
and the crown was like you can't that's
not legal and they're like we don't care
so at a certain point humans just make
decisions to do things and so we might
sit back and be like you can't do that
the court says this and it's like bro
the judge is gonna do whatever they want
and good luck
if you get a bad judge what are you
gonna do about it well that's why you
have an appeals process i know it's cool
but what have you got a bad supreme
court
yeah well right you may reject it it's
just
no that's that that's true i mean it we
we live in a fallen world and in a legal
system that has
limitations on its ability to do justice
yeah
but but i i will say just in defense of
the legal system in some ways we are
blessed and fortunate in the united
states
there
where we do i i believe in most cases
um civil cases that i've been involved
in certainly judges that are trying to
do
their best to reach reach the right
result
so we do have we do have that blessing
here in the united states that a lot of
other countries don't have no i mean we
got a pretty good system i think the
issue is just we're getting to this
point culturally where you have two
distinct americas you have the
multicultural democracy you have the
constitutional republic you have you now
have judges it you know i understand
sometimes you'll get a judge and i've
watched law order right right they'll be
like this is good news you know we've
got judge smith who's you know not a fan
of x or y which means we'll probably be
able to get you know these things filed
or something like that they'll say stuff
like that right and i've been involved
in legal issues in the real world where
i've been advised if you file in this
jurisdiction you're gonna have this
judge and he really hates this stuff
and so it's like okay you take those
things into consideration
that's to a degree understandable the
perceptions of the judges and how they
interpret the law but we're getting to
the point where these judges are like i
hate alex jones he's an evil man cnn
told me so i'm not going to let him win
no matter what he does it is we're
getting we're getting to that point i'm
not saying this of the current judge
some people are accusing i'm saying
quite literally
like i'm saying it's hypothetical we're
getting to the point where your judge is
going to be like i don't i don't know or
care who you are you're maga
and that's obviously
not a place where we need to be and
that's a disturbing place
it's a scary place that's where we're at
if anything alex jones was the one who
got defamed because after
his sandy hook comments they twisted
that into saying that he also claimed
parkland didn't happen and all sorts of
things didn't happen none of that was
true they brought up how like some of
the stuff he was saying was him reading
comments from users
and news articles
and so it's like
there should also be room for alex jones
to be a performer because that's partly
what he is
i i don't like i don't like the idea
that um look the sandy hook families
these are private individuals you don't
you don't get on a big platform and
start accusing private individuals of
stuff you shouldn't do it for anybody
right i didn't watch that
what he said at the time yeah i mean he
had he had his own ploy his own
employees were telling him to stop what
did he say exactly is it public uh is it
on youtube i don't think that you're
allowed to repost what he said on
youtube it's it's it's not and i would
not be able to quote exactly what he
said but i know there were various
instances of him accusing them of being
christ actors or saying they weren't
real but a lot of it was him
being like oh look what this person said
and look what this person said
and then they've also they also accused
him of saying things like if you really
did lose your children i'm so sorry and
they were like what does that mean and
they were saying those statements as
well were part of the defamation what
you got to understand about private
individuals
you can't like the standard is really
low for for defamation against a private
individual
or i shouldn't say it's really low it's
just really high if you're a public
figure
so what they tried doing with the
covington catholic kids was claiming
they were involuntary public figures
like that's absurd
but alex didn't get a jury trial in this
as to whether he defamed him so we
didn't even go over that stuff
jones was instructed that he was not
allowed to say that he was that he
didn't do it he was not allowed to
defend himself at all they said
he he wasn't allowed to say he comply
with discovery and he wasn't allowed to
say he he didn't defame them and he
wasn't allowed to say that he didn't
mean to call them and cause them
intentional harm
why couldn't that's crazy
and on the first issue about not being
able to say he wasn't liable
that was already
the decision it was a truck it was a it
was a trial on damages so that's not
out of the ordinary um at all right
because if you're only there to try
damages you
the issue of liability is already it is
out of the ordinary right it was rare
that there's a default right correct
correct right right so the fact that he
never got an opportunity correct like
here's what happened correct that being
said i gotta tell you guys
um
before the trial even happened i know
people who people have told me it's here
say but they were like i heard so and so
said to jones you have to stop doing
this
and then in the trial they actually
brought up communications where
employees at infowars were telling him
like why are you doing this it's not
worth it you need to stop
and he didn't and you know people have
brought up that he was drinking
probably got arrogant i mean this dude
was making a lot of money he was making
what like here's the crazy thing they
said it was like 16 uh i'm sorry 165
million in sales
165 million dollars in sales
i also i also heard scuttlebutt was like
he was making like 10 million a month
so if you're doing you know 165 million
per year
so you're so if it's if you're making 10
million imagine what his profit margins
are some speculate it was around 70
percent
makes sense it's a lot of money it's a
lot of money and and i'll tell you this
too like the 4.1 million i know it's bad
there's precedent like they're trying to
get a political victory or whatever it
is people think
the the thing about this 4.1 million is
i'm willing to bet jones got
crypto or something you know he knew
this was coming
so you have to imagine that if you know
it's coming and you're running work in a
company you're going to start you're
going to ramp up everyone's salaries
your kids are going to get their
inheritance very quickly
and then they're going to come through
and be like it's all gone you're
ordering your fair
you are ordering your affairs
strategically yep at that point though
there are
uh remedies potentially that these
plaintiffs can take to try to trace that
money to some extent but yes well let me
let me ask you then as a lawyer like if
uh if alex jones paid a million dollars
to an employee could they then get that
money back
well the problem is what what did the
what did the employee do right after
they after they got it right let's say
let's say let's let's say that someone
was contracted to uh
produce a documentary
and
uh they're a documentary filmmaker and
alex said we'll give you uh a million
dollars to produce this this massive
documentary and they said you got it
it's a third party let's say it's a
third-party company that's contracted
with alex jones
could you how would you get the money
from them i mean they're not involved in
your lawsuit you can't just take the
money from them they're doing work right
yeah i mean provide provided it's a
legitimate arms length transaction
that's not
right
fraudulent no yeah sure it's like an
invoice came in and it said here's the
proposed budget for the film right and
they said we're going to pay you the
million dollars
what do you do and and and that gets
into the interplay of you know potential
bankruptcy questions which i'm not a you
know i'm not an expert in in bankruptcy
um but uh fraudulent transfers and
things of that nature where creditors
will go and try to but i'm saying not
not fraudulent like right let's say alex
jones has never done a million dollar
documentary before right gets sued and
then he decides to do one
now he's broke because he spent all the
companies money used to him he said i
don't know any money they say where is
it we we spent it i'm running the
company right and and then you show like
a legitimate invoice and transaction and
budgeting plan for this big project
right and then that's what you think is
happening with the upcoming documentary
what he's doing that that is
actually documentary alex's war is not
related to m4 i'm not i'm not i'm not
going to contract that in any way no i'm
not i'm not referring to anything about
alex jones i'm saying like in the event
that you get sued couldn't you just
spend the money
well and whoever's hands it belongs to
yeah see that that's their private
business right
and then like you couldn't take i
couldn't take your money
you know if i was suing ian and
right now
and again i think what would happen is
you you would have to apply the you
would have to apply the law
uh in the case law in the jurisdiction
where you're in in his case in texas
as they're going to go and try to
collect against him personally they're
going to try to collect against these
corporations then you're gonna have a
overlay with the bankruptcy court and
how
uh the bankruptcy process plays out and
which uh who's gonna get paid and what
priority because i imagine he has
other creditors not just these judgment
creditors that are out there that uh
that uh he owes money to right so yeah i
don't i don't i don't it's a four
million dollar judgment and i'd be
surprised if they actually even get any
money i mean they might get a little bit
what are they what's going to happen i
mean
right right because they it sounds like
they might have to get in line right
with a lot of other people yep in the
bankruptcy price and then there's
questions of like
let's say alex jones just says
i declare bankruptcy i liquidate the
assets i pay everybody off and then he
takes a lucrative contract working for a
different company and so sure out of his
the money they're paying him maybe they
only pay him a small you know six figure
salary so he only has to pay a certain
percentage but then he gets to live
luxuriously you know through other
people
like he's alex jones he could take a
cell phone with 20 bucks and film a
video and get a million views right so
it's you know let's jump over to this
next story though we'll move off the
alex jones that was that was big news
and i thought it was really important
considering you know what's been going
on but this is the big national story we
have this from cnn politics the button
administration
has declared monkey pox a public health
emergency
uh-oh the announcement came during a
briefing with the department of health
and human services the administration
has been criticized at times for its
handling of the outbreak since the first
u.s monkey pox case was identified
mid-may more than 6 600 probable or
confirmed cases have been detected in
the united states case had been
identified in every state except montana
and wyoming the declaration follows the
world health organization announcement
last month that monkey pox is a public
health emergency of international
concern the who defines a public health
emergency of international concern as an
extraordinary event that constitutes a
public health risk to other states
through the intention through the
international spread of disease and to
potentially require a coordinated
international response
okay well
look according to i think it's the world
health organization
95
of those who have been infected have
been men who have sex with men
and so there was a story where they were
saying you know
actually i'll just put it this way in
new york city if you want to get a
vaccine in order to be eligible you have
to be a a man who a male who has
intercourse with males and have had
multiple anonymous partners that's how
you qualify for the vaccine they're not
just giving this vaccine to anybody they
also said male identifying so really i
guess women can get the monkey pox
vaccine too
as long as you're claiming to
get with a bunch of guys i guess dude
this is like a struggle session they're
like you know what you got to do if you
want the vaccine here's our guidelines
go get them super base that montana and
wyoming
don't have it
i mean why do you think all the
californians want to move there yeah but
it's it's not so much that it's super
base like
i i drove through wyoming and i thought
i was gonna run out of gas
because i'm driving down this highway
for like 200 miles and it's just road
and then
there was this small shed looking
building and i'm like i got like 50
miles left in the tank and i'm driving
and then my friend goes look
and there's two there's two gas pumps
that i couldn't even tell were gas pumps
and i was like whoa and then we pulled
over immediately and it was like this
dude in his house with like a little dog
walking around and he had gas
and i was like well okay so yeah it's
really hard to transmit diseases in
environments like that beautiful though
very very pointed out that 95 at least
is the number i've heard of them is it
sounds like it's an std trans
transmitted by guys having sex with guys
it's not an std that's a very important
distinction
people have been saying that because of
what they're reporting it's just that
for obvious reasons
people who have multiple anonymous
partners they're touching each other a
lot and they're sharing bodily fluids a
lot so there's a higher higher
propensity to bro i guess that's true
because the common cold isn't an std and
you could get it by having sex with
someone and if you go and shake the hand
of somebody who's got it and then you
get it you're going to be like i swear i
wasn't going so is it because it's it's
not a blood disease it's a skin-to-skin
contact disease that it's not considered
an std
yeah well it's not an std i want to
point out that just because someone
declares something doesn't mean that
it's actually real like i declare this
piece of obsidian is blue it's still
black uh so that they're
well hold on i mean he's saying it's an
emergency like that but that opens up
the fda we're talking about this before
the show to start making met approving
medicine for emergency authorized use
without proper testing channels if it's
considered an
emergency yeah yeah so i mean the the
phe being declared does uh does open the
door for
for medications vaccines other testing
uh diagnostics to
be
brought onto the market through instead
of going through the traditional fda
approval process through the abbreviated
eua process the emergency use
authorization process what bothers me
the most is that we've been softened i
think people have been softened to what
it means a medical emergency actually is
since kovid like that people are willing
to
to tend that this might actually be a
real emergency i mean it might be a real
emergency dude well might is a different
story now i'm okay well
i'm saying in my opinion like the
reality is the government has declared
it so they're claiming it is my point is
people can get monkey pox from touching
other people and so while it's spreading
predominantly among
one particular group
it could find its way if people don't
take it seriously into general
population
like regular people will start popping
and be like how did this happen and then
all of a sudden we got bumps or whatever
there's some crazy post on social media
where they're like if you're going to a
kink event just put band-aids over your
bumps
it's like well that's why it's spreading
so
i don't know man i don't know what
they're going to do the same thing this
is a little same thing that's going on
in arizona it's taken two days to count
this vote in 2020 for the first time it
takes days to count votes and people
have been softened to it it's like it
happened in 2018 so it's but it's a
pretty new phenomenon where it's taking
multiple days to count a city's votes
well it's not and also 2000
maybe yeah and that was like well yeah
the recounts right right so it has
happened but like
i don't want to see people get like
like muted to the the what a real
emergency is because we keep being told
that we're in a state of emergency
we've we've like i don't think we've
ever not been in a state of emergency
our entire life since since september
11th 2001 it's been an emergency every
day
even before i love this country but it's
there's there's how many emergencies are
currently and are currently active in
the united states
it's there's probably dozens because
they they never just end them they're
like oh yeah 911 emergency and then they
just leave it
and then it's an emergency and then they
can do all this crazy stuff and it's
it's uh threatening to our liberties
right it's
a constant state of emergency as we saw
in with the in many ways unprecedented
restrictions on individual freedom
that happened in this country during the
covet 19 pandemic during the phe more
than 30 national emergencies remain in
effect wow what's the oldest one
so they say uh the legislation was
signed by president gerald ford on
september 14th 1976 as of march 2020 60
national emergencies have been declared
more than 30 of which remain in uh in
effect
so uh you know we're just sitting there
okay there's uh 42 currently in effect
we have them
let's take a look list of national
emergencies in the united states
all right let's see we got 42 still in
effect look at this liz it's huge let's
go all the way down
all right under biden you've got a
security emergency invocation of
emergency authority relating to the
regulation of the anchorage and movement
of russian-affiliated vessels to united
states ports
and we got this one biden protecting
certain property of
da afghanistan bank
duh
for the benefit of people of afghanistan
you've got sanctions
you've got sanctions sanctions sanctions
sanctions you've got trump trump's
emergencies are still in effect current
current current
so this one ended under trump here's a
current trump one declaring a national
emergency concerning the novel
coronavirus okay that we understand um
blocking property and suspending entry
of certain persons contributing to the
situation in syria
let's go back pre-trump let's go to
obama
here's a current obama one blocking
property relating to venezuela
you've got uh
central african republic i mean these
are all emergencies man a lot of them
are sanctions a lot of them are
sanctions geez like 90 percent of them
public health
sanctions yeah that was h1n1
is that still so the green ones are
still going on a lot of sayings it's
like all sanctions basically to be fair
legal what's that one legal protecting
the development fund for iraq and
certain other property in which iraq has
interest what does that mean
it's an emergency we got to make sure
that the iraqis get their land what the
heck is going on
dude that's been in effect since 2003
wow that's a george bush emergency there
crazy dude h1n1 isn't current right no
no i mean i think it's still it's still
around and stuff under bush at a trade
august 17 2000 continuation of export
regulations emergency declared okay it's
not an emergency anymore iraq's taken
care of we're not even our troops are
pulled out like
no they still yeah we're still
technically we're supposed to have by
now but
arms current proliferation of weapons of
mass destruction emergency under bill
clinton 1994. what does that mean i mean
obviously amazing summary but what is
that oh here we go carter sanctions
still in effect blocking iranian
government property that's not a
surprise okay you know what i'll say
this i get it it's mostly sanctions i
understand but there's like seizure
under biden the people of afghanistan or
whatever the emergency declarations give
them just like blanket powers to do a
bunch of crazy stuff
yeah and we saw that on full display
during the covet 19 pandemic
unprecedented restrictions on individual
freedom lockdowns people
in my home state of north carolina a
legal state of the legal state of play
was if you didn't have a reason
to be out of your house
if you weren't going to the grocery
store or trying to get medical care
then
you could be held liable for a criminal
misdemeanor you see that video of that
lady who owned the restaurant
and she set up an outdoor seating area
and then california shut it down but
right next to it was a movie production
company's outdoor spreading area that
was up and running yeah she was crying
making a video about it because it
destroyed her business
you will own nothing and you will be
happy
i heard from so many people in 2020 as
this was starting
people who
had invested their livelihoods into
starting businesses
in my home state
and
they were completely devastated by the
restrictions and buy the lockdowns and
then you had ppp money that was being
supposed to go to these people and one
of the dirty little secrets of the legal
profession is a lot of that money i can
tell you went to law firms
in in 2020 and 2021 and law firms by the
way that never locked down or shut down
and and as i came back into private
practice learned many of them had record
years in 2020 so wow
so
wow
well yeah and and and you know i mean
i'll speak to this as somewhat of a
traitor to my class but it's disgraceful
that working class men and women
who that money was really there for to
keep
to keep them uh
making ends meet
you know we're losing their livelihoods
while partners and in mid-sized law
firms were paying down their beach
houses that's a disgrace i'm sorry i
just had a crazy thought
what if the elites
the wealthy
are trying to strangle out
the working class
then
fund
advocacy for communism
by going to the working class and being
like man your life sucks like yeah
communism look at this you know no no
well yeah yeah that's probably
yeah and then these people old ancient
practice strip people of their needs and
then promise to give them back yeah yeah
what was it what was it uh fast and
furious four i think it was the villain
in that in that uh movie it was
brilliant
he was like
he was like giving uh he was helping the
locals giving him stuff and he was like
if you give them something then they
fear having it taken away and then
they're slaves or something like that so
it's kind of like
take people who are in in dire straits
and give them just enough and then you
can threaten to take away what very
little they have we've got to get back
to
viewing the federal government as
something that we are allowing to exist
it's basically a union that we as
uh citizens of our states are allowing
to function it's not
there to control us it's there because
we want it to be there it doesn't have
authority over us we are it it is part
of us and it's supposed to work in
synergy with us to make sure that no one
state goes rogue and starts destroying
its citizenry that's basically the
function of the fed federal government
and and yet we have a very powerful as
we all know uh central government that
that really regulates
all aspects in many ways of our lives
right or at least if you're in a
commercial endeavor of any kind alphabet
suit of agencies and red tape and
regulations and all that comes with it
the professional class that's around it
the consultants the
lobbyists and yes the lawyers that that
are are a part of that ecosystem right
um so yeah i mean
the original intent of the republic
as you as you pointed out right a
limited federal government with most of
the powers being
reserved to the states and to the people
where they could act locally and
uh and govern themselves well i got good
news we're going to jump to this next
story from legal insurrection desantis
suspends state attorney for refusing to
enforce bans on child
surgeries
and abortion restrictions this this
morning um
ronda sanchez did this announcement
where he basically said
this george soros-backed state attorney
was
outright refusing to enforce the law in
a blanket statement and he was like look
it's one thing if you use your
discretion on an individual basis like
okay this guy shouldn't be charged with
this crime for this one reason here's
why it's another thing when you come out
you sign a document saying i will never
enforce the law so ron desantis as the
executive of florida
suspended the state's attorney and then
put in a temporary replacement to
actually enforce the law this is
tremendous
george soros uh uh recently issued a
statement
he published an op-ed saying he will not
back down from this he will keep funding
district attorneys to reform the system
or i should say he will keep fighting to
reform the system of prosecution because
it's not working for our communities
it's creating distrust between the
people and the police the crazy thing is
this guy is either completely evil or
dumb as a box of rocks and considering
his wealth he's as wealthy as he is i
don't think he's that stupid
if you look at what's happening in san
francisco chicago new york los angeles
yeah i don't think anyone's going to be
convinced this plan is working you look
at san francisco and they recalled that
guy just said boudin or whatever his
name is they recalled him the new the
new person who came in says they're
going to go after all the drug dealers
now so clearly whatever it is that soros
is thinking is funding is pissing
everybody off ron desantis
he's draining that swamp it's one of the
one of the one of the first major moves
i've seen from any executive to go
against these corrupt
states attorneys we'll see if anyone
goes after the district attorneys if to
the extent that they can but this is
huge huge huge victory for
accountability and maybe we'll start
seeing some stuff and then on top of
that you know i'll just add this before
throwing it to you guys donald trump
said he was going to fire everybody i
dig it
ron desantis just fired a guy i mean he
didn't really suspended him but uh i
think that's fairly promising for if
rhonda sanders ends up running for for
president 2024
yeah i really agree with that i'm not i
got mixed feelings about authority
authority authoritation authorities
using their power to just fire somebody
that's not doing bending to their will
but there is a reason for that his will
though it's just the law
that he's not designed he didn't put the
law personal
people voted people voted for a
legislature who then passed bills and
had them signed then it got a sufficient
amount of votes and then rhonda said
it's like i okay yeah sign the bill and
then this guy he issued a statement he
was like i am signing a statement saying
i will never enforce that law so
hopefully if desantis has integrity even
if it's a law he personally disagrees
with he would do the same thing
yeah yeah i think the second what i was
the second part of what i was saying is
that sometimes the authority
with the reason they have the ability to
fire somebody that's not bending to
their will is because you know we need
authority we need a strong leader at
least society our species since the dawn
of time has like an authority the
military commander the
commander-in-chief the one that's like
put him up against the whatever they're
like you're not gonna you're not gonna
support the military cause you're a
danger to our freedom and our
survivability the power i have the
ability to do with you what i will but
the power here that's being exercised
it's limited ron desantis doesn't decide
what the law is
he does however it is within his duties
to to make sure that if other people
within government aren't doing their
jobs if they're derelictive duty or
negligent that he removes them and
that's in the constitution
i i'm so surprised to see such a bold
move because it feels like especially
with the republican party they just sit
on their hands
now ronda sanchez is like he came out
and he just went at it and he was like
nah get him out of there here's boom
executive order did it say is this like
a temporary suspension
they're trying to make it permanent but
they've put someone else in in place
what do you think about it yeah i mean
it is
you know it's interesting with the left
the left is uh supportive of
local control and localism when it suits
its purposes and then it's supportive of
centralized control and authority uh
when it doesn't and
so you know here you've got somebody
who's a prosecutor who's essentially
involved in prosecutorial nullification
right essentially you've got a duly
enacted statute that's passed by the
florida legislature signed into law by
the governor and this prosecutor is
refusing to enforce the law as as you
said tim right he's
uh he's not just exercising discretion
on individual cases he's
saying
he's basically giving the finger to the
people of the state of florida by
refusing to enforce the law
so you know it is it is
good to see
someone stand up and say no you are
going to do this yo you are going to
follow the law you are going to apply it
and
and and you know in a red state where
there are these blue enclaves right that
this is a red state and this is the way
we do things here let me read this quote
in june of 2021 he signed a letter
saying that he would not enforce any
prohibitions on sex change operations
for minors
sex changes are really disfiguring these
young kids and he said it doesn't matter
what the legislature does in the state
of florida florida has said you cannot
perform sex change operations on
children this guy said he would not
enforce a prohibition on that i just got
to say
i don't think anyone predicted because
we had rick santorum here i don't think
anyone predicted that a slippery slope
meant within 10 years you would have
children getting sex change surgeries
now a bunch of news outlets they refer
to it as gender affirming health care
and i take issue with that because that
is not what ron desantis said
specifically ron desantis is citing
surgery operations like going to
children we
i don't think society would tolerate
breast implants that's a gender
affirming treatment right no gender
psychological thing it has once you
start to carve up physical bodies it's
another it's sex that's or or it's at
least non-sexual surg surgery
gender is an idea it's a concept it's a
way of feeling it once you start cutting
into it man that's that's another
well that's true
gender identity is different from gender
so these are these are uh post-modern
definitions of what gender is that's
gender was used since it started coming
into prominent prominence in the 50s to
specifically mean biological sex that's
that's very confusing because sex means
sex
gender means gender so you get they're
different words with different meanings
that's very important
so that's that's that's actually a new
concept that's so funny the different
words
gender and sex is new
so that you can have the identity be
anything you want but i thought it used
to be your sex was what you your your
gonads basically and then your gender
was how you identified and it didn't
have to be no one identified as anything
they were just
what they were yeah like the 50s
it appeared that this idea of gender was
like in the 50s or something like that
so the word
the word the word gender has been used
for a long time it comes from genre
actually i was looking at the history of
the word it came into prominence in the
50s with people like uh john money and
um
i don't was kinsey the 50s i'm not
entirely sure sheamus knows all about
this yeah and so i started reading a bit
about it but um gender was used as a
word
academically they were trying to say
it's like the social constructs around
it but colloquially for most of
of english-speaking humans it just
referred to your biological sex
oh kinsey was 1947 it was when he
founded the institute for research and
sex gender and uh what was the other one
yeah so most people when they say gender
reproduction on your legal form it says
gender m or f
right if it says gender and its
reference to male or female they're not
talking about how you feel
they're asking you about your body and
you know why they do because this is
really important in the early 1990s
there was a law that was passed
when they would do medical testing they
wouldn't do it on women
and then all of a sudden people started
realizing something you know those
painkillers we use to insert during
surgeries women keep complaining that
it's not working hey wait a minute
hypothesis maybe these drugs don't work
on women sure enough they found out that
certain painkillers
work on men and women differently and so
then there was a law pass saying when
you're doing medical testing you have to
have female and male trials this is why
it's very important they know what your
biological sex is
now that they're changing the definition
of gender and then changing it back it's
the funny thing um
we're getting to this point where
there's a reason that we ask these
questions
if you if if someone collapses on the
street
and and a medic runs up
it's it's it actually is important that
they know if you are male or female for
a variety of reasons for instance if a
man screams and says ah my my my gut oh
man it's hurting right in my pelvic area
well there's a very different reason
that that may be happening compared to
what would be happening to a woman
but it could be appendicitis and it
could be a bunch of other things and so
there are some things for obvious
reasons men and women have different
organs that a pain in a certain area
could be something or some could be one
thing or not for obviously but my point
is
there are certain medical treatments
they will give to a male not a female
and if they can't tell or they don't
know or they don't know that a person is
taking drugs for for you know gender
affirmation as they're calling it well
then you could be seriously screwed up
when a medic gives you a medication that
it's counterindicated by whatever it is
you're taking yeah you've got to make
sure that people don't you there's a
story of a woman that was following
google maps or something or apple maps
into the des and it was telling her to
turn left go straight and she just kept
following the computer into the desert
her car broke it was the wrong direction
so if someone just is like thinking
gender is all that matters what i think
is all that matters they're basically
driving their car on this automated
concept if it gets to a point where you
need to to perform life-saving medical
treatment on that person and then you do
the wrong sex because they've conflated
what they feel with gender and their sex
then it's just like
it could end up being catastrophic for
someone right now the life-saving
medical treatment that they're referring
to is gender affirmation because
essentially
they're holding these kids hostage
in a way
saying like they're going to commit
suicide if they don't get these
treatments do you want them to commit
suicide
yeah they're holding them hostage and
and the i think what's what's what's the
crazy thing about it is if you look at
countries scandinavia for instance
they've stopped doing all this
they there was like a there's a big
article i was reading the day sweden is
like they're doing mental
you know therapies and stuff right now
because perhaps a solution to someone
who's got suicidal ideation is not
affirming what is driving their ideation
isn't scandinavia or maybe just the
netherlands where assisted suicide uh
i don't think the netherlands is
scandinavian are they i don't think i i
don't like fencing i was thinking it was
either in scandinavia or in the
netherlands
so it's uh like like sweden had this big
move where they were like we're not
gonna do this i don't know exactly where
they're at now but i know people have
been talking about the scandinavian
countries being like we have found that
it's not actually reducing suicidal
ideation and so that that's my thing
it's like seriously we don't want kids
harming themselves has it been found
that it worsens
suicidal ideation i don't think no i i i
don't know i don't keep up with that
yeah i've read that it's um
i've read some articles saying it's like
no difference
um but obviously it depends on what you
read if you read like advocacy websites
they're going to say of course it's
helping reduce these things and it's
like oh maybe i don't know what i do
know is
what these other countries have have
written news articles from these
countries that i've read is that
the mentality is if someone is
experiencing suicidal ideation
affirming what it is that is that is
contributing to it is not necessarily an
appropriate solution so if someone is
feeling
you know let's just say dysmorphic a
general dysmorphia like anorexia or
eating too much or you know they want
amputations or whatever
they were like
giving a person who is suffering from
some kind of anxiety
that tree like what they're asking for
is probably not the appropriate way to
stop them from feeling this way it's
kind of like if if your kid is afraid
that there's a ghost under their bed and
you're like
yeah there is a ghost under your bed and
then you start building their room to
protect from this fake ghost and then
the kid goes even crazier because it
starts to think really that that but
i agree that you do need to affirm these
people not in you need to affirm their
existence people need to be heard and
understood and listened to that's what
these people need more than anything you
don't need to start i mean put the
knives down for a minute and listen to
these people like jazz jennings we were
listening to a video from her last night
she just released a book i don't
necessarily agree with what's in the
world the books
so she's got a book up for all but she
needs to be listened to we all need that
we and it's not like it's it's do it or
or the world blows up but to survive and
for the betterment of humanity people
need to be listened to
jazz jennings person
had parents who
seemed to impose this identity
since
a very young age like two years old when
they see they see their their child who
they think is a boy wearing a towel
on his head and then they're like okay
you're a girl now and jazz said put them
on tv and we're just supposed to
accept that as as normal
and watch it
yeah that's our entertainment now this
is what concerns me about uh jazz in
particular is the uh
she put out a video
saying that since two two years old
she's felt this work or whatever
and and i'm i have concerns first memory
is even that early
yeah that's insane you know like i have
can you guys remember when you were i
remember peeing on my brother one time i
think i was like four and he was like
yeah he was two i'm still being two
years old i don't know i don't know so
so look certainly i'm not as complex as
that i do have questions though like if
if we're gonna talk about florida and
the parental rights and education stuff
and the rights of the parents to choose
for what's right for their kids
then you have to define what your moral
line is because if we're then going to
question the parents of jazz jennings
it's like
do we then intervene in their family as
a governmental body do we say the
government must intervene or stop that
if we think it's wrong or do we then say
we don't want the government intervening
in what parents think is right for their
kids
and there's questions of
if if a kid really is
you know suicidal and i'm not talking
about two years old
and
doctor prescribes something
do we as the layman then say we've
decided to intervene i mean
let's let's keep our more our our
morality logical right in the same path
so i'm on high alert against medical
tyranny and for-profit surgeries on kids
is devastating it's really bothering me
but i i think people also should have
the freedom to do what they want with
their bodies now we talk about a kid
kids don't have the ability to consent
to things the parents basically
consenting for them and so is it ethical
for a for a 45 year old parent to have a
13 year old kid cut i don't know i don't
yeah what about the kids that are that
have adopted that identity before
they're adults and then once they're
adults
they
continue to
to keep that identity and seek medical
procedures because of it
i don't think that that person has
informed consent of what of the
procedures that they're seeking well i
don't i don't think children can consent
so right but once they're adults and
they've they've already been groomed to
believe that this is who they are
they don't have the ability to make an
informed
consensual decision about the about the
medical treatments i don't agree with
that at all yeah i can't make that
decision for others
that negates everyone's life
you know look i i don't think children
should be getting sex change surgery i
think that's like where we're we're
going on a dangerous path but to say
that
you know you're 16 and you had an
experience that informed you of
something and you chose to follow that
so you can't be adequately informed
because of that okay jazz jennings since
two years old
the parents have been in charge of that
and right from what i'm saying
and then jazz jennings
18 and up
now has the ability to consent to
further
medical interventions
well i think after being groomed so
thoroughly into believing that
that
that is their identity
i see what you're saying
but the challenge doesn't follow
there's there's this is such a
there's like a hard line for obviously
like don't give sex changes to kids that
i can't believe is actually a political
debate that's happening right now and
to what extent does the government
intervene when someone prescribes a
medical treatment to a child you don't
agree with
so
i'm at a loss to to to be to be honest
like i i think it's great what uh ronnie
sanders did i think that if you've got a
law that's been you know from do
duly elected
and a bill has been sworn this is the
question this is the question for social
media what is what is what is youtube's
position on the fact that in florida it
is a crime
to perform a sex change on a child
how do are
our youtubers advocating for illegal
activity now
no you you what's what are the rules
so i i'm saying for me
i look at what's going on in florida
we have consistently said over the past
year
parents should have the final say in
what their kids are are you know and how
to raise their kids
and then you get people coming out and
saying okay well my doctor said my kid
should undergo this treatment and it's
like no i think you should uh wait a
minute i just said parents should have
final say yeah but
those obvious lines though like if a
parent was abusing the child and then we
have to decide what those moral lines
are simply put florida has decided no
sex change surgery for kids yeah i mean
and in north carolina i can tell you uh
we had an interesting proposal made by
the
duke law school around homeschooling and
my wife and i homeschool our kids
and there was a proposal that was put
forth to amend north carolina's
child abuse laws to define something
called educational neglect
so what's educational neglect under this
proposal well when you start to boil it
down it really means
if you're not providing an education
that a judge
deems to be adequate so
ultimately you know judges make make the
call
but it becomes you know sort of
inherently politicized so am i am i
giving my child an adequate education if
i'm teaching them that there are only
two you know male and female
um am i giving my child an adequate
education if i'm teaching them um you
know
uh real american history right like um
so
you know
to your point students subject to
standardized testing
it depends on the state in north
carolina you have to test i think it's
every two years
that's messed up i'm totally opposed to
to uh to run a run a home school
but you know do you draw lines to say
for what parents can do right in terms
of okay there's a difference between how
you're going to educate your kids right
and your control over the education your
kids versus
making these kinds of decisions about
your child's future and the ability of
society to second-guess those decisions
this is this we have a cultural problem
it always comes down to this and i i is
what i want people to understand
if a parent says i'm gonna show my kids
graphic images it's like okay well now
you've got questions like
is the violation of the law does the law
define showing lewd images to children
does you can't do that however the
problem is these parents are going to
doctors and the doctors saying this is
what you have to do
not only that
but often when the parents defy the
doctors the state comes in in certain
states and punishes the parents
so now you've got this this is a this is
i'm telling you man
when i talk about the bifurcation of
this country
in florida for instance sex change on on
children not allowed
in in other states i mean even in texas
we saw that case where the mom wanted to
transition the son the the little boy
and the dad didn't and there was like
the judge ruled in favor of the mom
so
you've got these stories about parents
who are like
a doctor said it
so they agreed and then what we're
supposed to say is like well you know
far be it for me to say what's what's
you know what's in the what what what
the child should get if a doctor is
saying it but then you have parents who
can't even decide in some areas when the
doctor says it they say no now they get
in trouble the inverse is florida
it's illegal to do like we're we are
we're getting to the point where you're
going to have two states next to each
other one's gonna florida completely
illegal then you're gonna have another
state being like totally legal and then
what the mother's gonna kidnap the kid
to bring them somewhere to get this
gender affirming health care or what
what uh florida refers to as prohibited
child sex changes even the language on
what's happening is totally different
it's kind of the way it's supposed to be
that every states gets to pick its own
way of being and then we have a federal
government to make sure that you don't
that there are some things that are just
off off the right off the books you
can't drive 180 miles an hour anywhere
in the country you can't kill people
legally you can drive well you can kill
my mind more permissible than child sex
changes yeah but ian you are incorrect
there are places in this country where
you can drive i was being hyperbolic and
off the off the hip that was stupid of
me uh on private property you can go as
fast as you want and they actually have
permitted areas where they do high-speed
testing so well but the point is there's
a semantic on you but you did a good job
there are things that the federal
government will say yo state you can't
say that's okay murder's not okay you
can't say that in your state you know
you can't abuse your citizens basically
i don't know i don't i don't know about
that is that true well i mean that's it
it really
you know it's an interesting question in
light of the dobbs decision right
because there are people on
you know the issue of abortion
uh who believe and there were briefs
that were submitted in that case
uh where
people took the position that abortion
is unconstitutional just flatly that
that unborn children are persons under
the 14th amendment and that
all states have to treat those persons
equally and so
if uh a state estate would have to
ban the murder of an unborn unborn child
so abortion is flatly prohibited
naturally i honestly under that analysis
versus sort of the more you know classic
conservative legal
approach to the question which is i
think what the court ultimately uh
adopted and dobbs which is that the
constitution is just silent on this
question and it's an issue for each
individual state to decide but how do we
it's not silent but but how does the go
well i
we talk about it quite a bit and you
know we talk about i don't i don't like
to just
abortion has been such a big topic on
the show for the past several weeks but
a viable baby that can survive outside
the womb
should be protected
gotta define viable like it can survive
outside the woman maybe
because like without a parent without
adults around it it'll just die outside
the world until it's like
yes quite literally
if a baby is is taken out of the womb
and placed on a table and it doesn't die
right away like it is breathing it is
looking around it is moving around
like i
my point is
if if a 30 year old man was was
lying on a bed unable to move we
wouldn't be like he's no longer viable
pull the plug we'd be like no that
person has rights and that has to be we
have to figure out how to manage an
individual who's been incapacitated the
point is
if the constitution protects
individual beings why would a viable
baby not be protected the same as a
comatose patient like whatever term you
come up with they're going to abuse the
term so
viable
they could say a baby isn't viable
because
the adults around the baby are obligated
to take care of it or else it will die
right until
quite an old age like i don't know when
kids are capable of using a reason to
fend for themselves
that's why i brought up a comatose
person
right there's already legal precedent on
that so why would that not apply to a
viable baby euthanasia is still
incredibly common yes but you need
like terry chavo comes up all the time
but let's just reference there's a
person who gets in a car accident and
they're now
in a coma
and they're like we don't know what's
gonna happen the person can't speak the
person can't eat we can keep them alive
you know
they still have rights you can't just
kill him
next if kin can make decisions for them
depending on you know because we have
legal precedent here so
the question then is
if if the person does have rights
and
this is a question of will
man this gets just too complicated it
really is because because the issue is
someone who's been in an accident who
might die is injured and is suffering an
injury a baby that is living is not
suffering an injury so so at that point
you have unimpeded will
be right born so i don't understand how
how there's an argument so like that's
why i look at the traditional row uh
argument which is pre-viability of a
question of
who's whose right i mean the baby cannot
survive without being blood dependent on
another individual and so there's a
question in my mind about the extent to
which the government can can mandate
that but once the baby can survive on
its own
in in open air how can you justify not
having giving it constitutional rights
because someone still has to take care
of it and you gotta that would be the
government mandating that someone else
has to do something
but i gotta stop you there because i
already already i i already rejected
that point and destroyed it but if the
if the mother's like okay then i don't i
don't have to do anything government i
can't kill it i'm just going to leave it
there yes neglect and it'll die so it's
a form of murder no it's not um there's
a big difference between intentionally
killing a baby and then putting it on
the doorstep of a post office or a fire
department that's different though i'm
just letting it lay there in the in the
living room on the ground until it dies
of starvation yeah neglect yeah so my
point is that that argument is just it's
it's already dealt with there are people
who are comatose and they have
constitutional rights
they do we we apply their rights to them
why would we not do it to a baby
i don't know because they hit their you
can you can take the baby and put it on
the doorstep of a fire department
legally and they have those safe havens
or whatever
so if that's the case like i just don't
know
that's just me you know i don't know
because
the motivations behind
the abortionists argument are not
about viability or rights or anything
it's just that they enjoy
hurting children
they enjoy freedom they enjoy their
freedom from from being i think they
don't have the closest thing you can get
to purely evil
i think it's an issue of
narcissism
the self-interest
man it was crazy uh at any cost
including another human being's life oh
yeah yeah matt matt walsh i think uh
announced he's gonna have some more kids
mm-hmm you guys see that and uh michael
knowles i think just welcomed his second
child oh my and um he may have they may
have been old foreign but uh someone
tweeted some leftist activists to i
think was matt walsh i'm sorry that your
wife was was brainwashed into being a
brood mare or something like that and
i'm just like that's so insane to say to
somebody
yeah
women's right to choose life
isn't valid right
i like this to each their own mentality
i i don't know i'm kind of hands off on
all this stuff i just gotta say i put it
simply for you guys and then we'll jump
on to the next story
the only thing i can say is
the end result of all of this is a
christian conservative united states of
america no not christian not do i have
anything to do with it but
how many kids do you have
i have all of yours no i michael knows
has too yeah but they're listening they
listen to these shows you know you you
can and this is what i'm saying about
jazz jennings in her book it's one thing
with what's the parent doing for their
child but it's and should the parent
have the right to have surgery on the
child but it's another thing when people
are
it's working outward and people are
affecting society through media and
convincing your child and somewhere else
of what to do or inspiring your child
you know you don't need to biologically
have children to influence children
that's for sure that's why the school
issue is so huge but my point is simple
um conservatives have been showing up
their communities they've been ron
desantis has been winning and removing
these people yeah i'm it looks like
right now there's a lot of variables
that lay before us but if everything
that's happening right now stays the way
it's happening and advances exactly the
way it's happening
30 40 years you're going to have
this country is going to be substantial
christ will have returned yeah probably
well i don't know crisis is going to
come unify the globe
well actually it would be really nice
right about now because uh here's what i
think is going to win history here's the
next story
china launches unprecedented military
drills on taiwan's coastal borders they
actually this is the crazy thing
apparently
one of those
multiple rockets from china have landed
in japanese territorial waters and now
they're
talking saying basically this may have
been an act of war
so we could really use someone to come
down and you unite this planet before we
blow ourselves up or come up and do it
you hear me out there you're listening
come up it's you you're the one are you
oh i thought you were talking about
satan no no just right coming up man
coming up in the world that's what it's
all come down and land on earth and
bring them together and then
civilizations that live in tunnels
underground that's what i was talking to
yeah and also be careful what you wish
for because if you were like we need
someone to come and bring peace this
planet you'll get somewhere like okay
and then you know
yeah and also unification anti-christ
come yeah right exactly it's like your
wishes might come in a decentralized
unification i think where it's like
locally run but organized like the the
states we have 50 states but they're all
run locally if canada joined us and then
we had like 70 states and they're all
run locally but we you know america is
basically the land we live on
that's that's yeah look at these look
look at these videos man
this is bonkers
china's firing missiles over taiwan
they're landing in japanese waters
i kind of feel like war like it's an
intimidation tactic
well for sure but i think it's an act of
war
they're in taiwanese territorial waters
they're in taiwan's
waters
firing missiles
i mean like right you can't show up in
front of someone's house without firing
gun in the air like you get arrested for
that so we're supposed to sit back and
just be like oh this is no big deal
there's nothing this is just safer
rattling i'm like dude they're literally
the missiles are landing like they're
hitting people's like other countries
territory
i kind of feel like the reason that uh
nancy pelosi went to
uh to to out to to taiwan
is because they know that something's
about to happen
that the chinese are going to bring
the taiwanese back into the fold of the
mainland
right i mean because that's their view
right the the chinese government's view
is that it's a breakaway province that
has always belonged to to china i'm
looking at what they're doing with the
beaching drills they've been doing sand
dredgers around taiwan
it's like dude they're getting ready
they're not screwing around they've been
they've been showing up their financial
defenses after after what happened with
russia and the sanctions right this
could be why the banks are in in dire
straits in the country because they're
getting ready
for when they go and take taiwan and i
don't i think nancy pelosi basically
went there and said
we will not back you
oh went to taiwan to let them know we're
out i think it was i think it was
essentially that like along those lines
why would you we're building factories
in the united states to build silicon
ships you're done
we we will not protect you right what is
how is the u.s going to protect taiwan
when mainland china is literally right
there no i don't i don't know
economically that'd be the only way
i mean we do have like
nuclear submarines off the coast and
stuff under the water but
yeah but it's like this is the way to go
trying to i mean look they're so close
to the island but then russia is vowing
to fight with china i think the us is
basically like if we defend you it's
world war three so we won't
is this going to be the united states as
soon as crisis if you think of the
british
empire and its decline it our
british inability to act in the suez
crisis uh similar potentially here
historical in that analog what happened
with the suez well the british just were
overextended it was after world war
ii
they were uh and peter hitchens talks
about this vividly uh the the essayist
and brother of christopher hitchens that
vividly remembers this happening
excuse me in the 1950s
that the british empire had been
exhausted by world war ii it was
overextended and it didn't have the
financial or military resources to act
in the suez crisis and they were told to
have take their hands off and there was
nothing that they could do and maybe
that's
the that's where we're headed right
that's where we are
we can't
we can't fight a war on the eastern
front in europe and the pacific theater
at the same time right
plus china's got resources in other
continents africa
they're not not to mention we talk about
1.3 billion uh chinese citizens yo
china's been engaging
uh in colonialism for the past couple
decades or longer people
people don't understand this
they have this image of colonialism as
like a bunch of people get on a
government boat and they're like we're
going to go discover a new world and
take it over and they think it would be
like a bunch of boats landing in chinese
citizens like taking over a town no they
get a visa they move in right that's it
and then sooner or later you've got
large portions of your cities and your
country are you know now settled by
citizens of a foreign country and then
one day if war breaks out what do you
think is going to happen in australia
like th this is why we had internment
camps in world war ii for the japanese i
think it was wrong but the idea was like
we don't know which one of these
japanese people may be loyal to the
japanese empire could it very easily if
we hadn't done that if they hadn't done
that it could have been like the
japanese uprising in california could
have been become japanese territory and
then we lose the war so it happened in
europe six years ago i think it was
maybe it was uh maybe it was five years
ago a bunch of turkish citizens were
waving turkish flags in various european
countries
and and erdogan was like we'll open the
floodgates because all of these people
loyal to a different country are in
these european countries
so what do you think happens
if the united states
a lot of people who live here are
citizens of
of china we've even had people come here
who are who are members of the chinese
communist party overtly right what about
australia
if a war breaks out
people start pointing the finger and
then this is the crazy thing like the
whole thing just becomes overtly racist
right
like people aren't going to be like how
can i tell if someone's chinese and
they're going to be like that's
like
they're just not going to trust each
other it's kind of a crazy crazy thing
to think about
maybe on a positive side on china i mean
there are a tremendous number of
christians in china
there's a huge underground church in
china
and um as unlikely perhaps as it seemed
in
the roman empire and
in in around 300
a.d when constantine converted to
christianity and changed the course of
history perhaps
uh something like that might happen who
knows right i'm trying to think
optimistically here yeah right that uh
that god will do something in china and
move
uh that country toward
toward christ ultimately aliens come
and then just uh bring medicine and
everyone just stops fighting and they're
like oh look we're not you know or yeah
but it's not but it's not like i said
right i mean but if you were in in in uh
in rome
in and around that time as a persecuted
christian in a tyrannical situation and
state it would have seemed equally bleak
and yet god did move in that country and
it changed the world and maybe and i
pray that that would happen in this case
uh that that god would move in china and
that great things would happen and uh
and that the country would change
culturally the past hundred years
are not um confidence-building
in terms of just the trajectory of
history yeah
you know i was reading i was reading a
tweet they said when uh when germany
invaded
poland nobody knew was the start of
world war ii
and it escalated and eventually it was
world war ii and that right now with
russia invading ukraine that's the
argument they're trying to make and
there's the the tweet was basically more
money for ukraine
stop russia now before it becomes world
war iii
and it's like
i get it
if uh now that finland and uh sweden
the the u.s senate has voted
overwhelmingly 95-1 holly was the only
one who said no
they voted to become inducted they voted
to be inducted into nato russia about
retaliation
that right there it's just like it's
crazy to me that you see you have
everybody who's running full speed
towards world war three intentionally
like you realize it's one thing to be
like china doesn't dictate where our
politicians go so plus is going to
taiwan it's another thing to at the
exact same time hold a vote to induct
sweden and finland donato when russia's
threatening war i'm like maybe a weight
right
they're just running full speed towards
world war ii controlled demolition yeah
just collapse
it's we're not it's not munich
1939 we're in uh we're we're in world
war one right the preconditions that led
to that the entangling alliances and the
dominoes that fell and the disaster that
unfolded that ultimately led to world
war ii and millions of people dead but
but
they're running towards it right like
you could be you couldn't someone come
out and be like i propose we don't vote
on this just yet because the tensions
with china are just too hot and we
should maybe wait a little bit
no let's let's ram it through yeah why
did holly
um dissent i don't like calling it
descent because it's not like it was a
pre-foregone conclusion or whatever it
was he just chose to not support the
thing why well we have this story here
we'll read josh hawley was the only
senator to oppose nato membership for
finland and sweden
is it in the united states interest said
hawley finland and sweden want to expand
nato because it is in their national
security interest to do so fair enough
the question that should properly be
before us however is
is it in the united states interest to
do so
because that is what american foreign
policy is supposed to be about i thought
i fear some in this town have lost sight
of that they think american foreign
policy is about creating a liberal world
order or nation building overseas with
all due respect they're wrong bravo
josh hawley rand paul voted present
i would have thought he would have voted
against it
that's this is amazing to me russia has
already got their people on tv talking
about nuking london
what do you think russia's going to do
think about it from the perspective of
the united states imagine if russia
started sending resources into mexico
and mexico was talking about joining the
russian trade federation and then a
bunch of central american countries were
joining a military alliance with with
russia
and then there was a a
basically in mexico the government gets
overthrown and a bunch of communists
like soviet people or russians take it
over
you'd be like okay we got ourselves a
problem in the gulf right yeah that
would be a problem so what we got to do
is ally with russia and the chinese and
then there will be a chinese uprising in
a republican uprising in russia i'm
looking forward to it
i suppose the what people need to
understand is that the us may talk about
its interest in expanding nato and
working with ukraine
but anyone who's sane understands why
russia is going to lose their mind over
it they're slowly being surrounded by a
massive military alliance and they don't
like it so
right at a certain point russia is going
to be like it's now or never
and then what do they nuke london no no
take crimea and the war i don't think
anybody wants that that war over there i
mean maybe the bankers do if russia
feels like they'll cease to exist that's
what they said they'll they'll they'll
go
you know full-scale nuclear war if they
feel threatened like
so we're going to the brink
that's what they want people to think
though too you got to remember and i
don't know who they are but that's like
people thrive off of like doomsday
scenarios monetarily media gets so many
clicks when people are afraid
so i don't know it's i get a lot of this
from western media from american media
it's true but the war in ukraine is
happening american citizens are on the
ground volunteers fighting the u.s is
supplying intelligence and weapons
nato is basically involved who was it
was it lithuania who blocked the
shipment of the klinengrad i think it
was lithuania you want to check that
real quick yeah uh and russia was like
this is an act of war and then they like
backed off
it's like yeah
russia is not just fighting that was
lithuanian yeah lithuania blocked tran
uh supplies into kaliningrad which is
six days ago russian territory six days
ago well then articles from six days ago
from tvp world are they um are they just
analyzing it or
maybe because this happened like a month
ago oh
i'm just saying
history is condensed and people don't
realize how condensed you know well
people don't even
understand the history of world war one
right i mean the average american oh
yeah doesn't understand what happened
tell me about it right i mean they they
they haven't read about it they don't
know that the united states didn't get
involved until
april of 1917
very late in the war um or even the the
united states wasn't involved in world
war ii until you know pearl harbor after
years
many years into it right so i mean we
don't
right we're not we're not being taught
that in our in our you know primary
education we're focusing on other things
that aren't
you know unfortunately uh
much less important than having this
overall understanding of the history of
the world and how it relates to this day
and time and you think about you know
nato right like as a republican holly
being the only person to vote against
nato expansion it's interesting to look
back historically was the great senator
from ohio robert alfonso taft bob taft
who
on the right as a conservative mr
republican voted against nato in the
first place in the first instance wow
there was a there was that that that
wing of the republican party that
conservative
right that that opposed
the the internationalism that uh
nato made sense i see both sides soviet
union right yeah so we see this was this
massive expansion of these communist
states and so we said okay we need to
push back against this expansion right
and but there were people there were
people on the right
uh pre-national review who rejected that
and said we don't need nato no we don't
need to police the world no we don't
need to have a worldwide war against
communism yes we we believe communism is
doomed to fail i mean i i i don't know i
i can't quote the person uh who said it
but uh you know some some maintain that
the most ardent believers in the
validity of communism were the people in
the kremlin and the conservative
movement in the united states
in the sense that we were going to amass
all of these resources against an
economic system we ultimately believed
was doomed to failure but there was that
that that counter um critique
uh from the right on on the cold war
pre-national review
when i think of world war one i think of
like uh was the assassination of uh
franz ferdinand written by uh gio
giovanni precha precepi pre-chappie
something like that but he was like a
serbian national i believe right killed
the
archduke of austria-hungary i believe
killed him and then austria-hungary
declared war on serbia i believe is that
what it was that's right and then
britain who was an ally of serbia like
made a nato like an alliance declared
war on austria hungary britain declared
war because they were an ally of of the
serbs so then relo gavrilo shep thank
you very much he and two other guys
tried to kill friends he was the one
that actually pulled it off but wasn't
it like he screwed up and then by luck
happened to have accidentally run into
him later on i don't know there was a
carriage going down the road they were
like hiding out and waiting they
couldn't get the thing he threw a
grenade in i think into the carriage and
killed franz ferdinand and his wife
right and then so after
austria hungary declared war on britain
i think one of britain's allies declared
war i'm sorry after britain declared one
austria-hungary then germany declared
war on britain and then france declared
war in germany uh some dumb stuff like
that all of a sudden you have
an inadvertently it's what they call
later a world war so we got to avoid
that that's what nato is setting us up
for is if something happens in sweden
then they declare war on russia or
russia declares war on on sweden because
some done in sweden national and then
britain declares war in russia like come
on guys come on
that's the wisdom of george washington's
farewell address right that america
should avoid
being in entangling alliances with
foreign countries to avoid precisely the
outcome that you're doing but the other
argument is if if we had not had the
defensive
alignment against nazi germany that he
would have taken poland and then he
would have taken
france and then he would have taken
italy and then he would have taken over
the world so
but you have to i think you you have to
start
with world war one to analyze everything
that happened right afterward um
and and in the circumstances that
led to
really uh
the most catastrophic war in human
history up to that point
um and and and what could have been done
to
to prevent it i mean it it it was it was
an
it was eminently in many ways
preventable
um war and the second world war no no
i'm talking about the world world war
one and the first then the great war the
great war right to war the war to end
all war wars the war at the war for you
know democracy and and freedom um but
again uh not well understood it seems
there's a youtube channel called the
great war i highly recommend it they
went from 2014 to 2018. every week they
would make a video talking about what
happened a hundred years before because
1940 was basically the centennial of
world war one and they would go week by
week every week there's a video about
17 million people died today uh in the
in the psalm or whatever in this on this
this four four month battle that went on
in eastern france between the british
and the the trench and then the germans
and it was just like kill kill kill kill
kill they take like
a half a mile of land and then the next
day they'd get it taken back and they
just kill death death death and it's
modern war they keep stressing in modern
war the most advanced weapons are used
you do not see it coming do not engage
in this stuff now that's my personal
statement on it do not engage in this
i i don't like appeasement though i
don't like the idea of like let the
conqueror conquer right but
i mean taiwan is right next to china
it's it's it's i don't know how far away
is it three miles away from the mainland
or something
i don't think it's that close how close
is it it's it's it's it's right off the
coast
dude what uh this is probably been
having this discussion for a hundred
thousand years but you know to your
point about what the people in 19 you
know 14 to 19 what 1918 went through
uh the the courage the the brutality of
it
and then you think about
the world that we live in today
and the difference that each and every
one of us can make in the world and
the comparatively little sacrifice that
we have to make right to make a
difference right whether it's
because standing for truth and justice
in our world today i mean what's the
worst that's going to happen to you you
might lose your job right you might lose
prestige you might lose you might you
might you might but you know you're not
being asked to
run into machine gun fire like those
guys were you know
in in in world war one there's a movie
called they shall not grow old i believe
that's the name of it um about world war
one where they colorized the footage
when you see the guys get out of the
trench and run and just fall down
because the machine gun right right i'm
reading about the uh what pulled the u.s
into world war one it's actually
a lot over several years the sinking of
the lusitania the ss arabic they were
attacked
wilson was was furious over unrestricted
submarine warfare
germany backed off and then ultimately
with the with the warfare going on the
german submarine offensive there was
food shortages happening in the united
states so then they were just like
public support started to ramp up people
were pissed i'm still reading a little
bit but yeah you're crazy because with
the world war two it was like we got
attacked
right we got attacked and we were like
all right that's it we're pissed world
war one the americans were funding the
british basically they were sending them
food and weapons and stuff so the
germans were like f this so they started
blowing up american transports and then
americans were like hey don't blow up
our transports we're just ferrying
people across the sea and the germans
were like no you're not y'all are going
to love this on april 6 congress
declared war on germany remember the
good old days when congress declared war
the the only the last time was
world war ii right was it really right i
think that's the last time the united
states declared war um
every other war right
the iraq war i mean i feel like that was
the end of the soul of the united states
then
you know we win world war ii and then
all of a sudden these these these
corrupt individuals are like well now
we're going to do limited warfare
kissinger yeah i was watching uh you
guys are watching the good place no no
i'm not i'm not that big of a fan but
i'm watching it because i've like
watched everything else basically it's
actually not bad it's a it's a slightly
it ended a few years ago but i was just
laughing because
the they were uh
in the end of the show they're like
referencing people on earth who did good
and then the demon guy he's like well
then i want to name bad people henry
kissinger and then i just started
laughing i was like that was a great
great reference for a teacher i would
love to meet kissinger someday because i
used to think of him as a just a vile
demon but now i'm like well maybe
limited war prevented world war iii at
the time you know i used to think of him
as a vile demon now i think him think of
him as a narcissistic sociopathic vile
demon you know intent on just causing
him and suffering so yeah you know it's
only gotten worse
it's only only worse if we could get
materials from place to place without
effort then we're talking then we don't
really need as much con we don't really
need conflict if we can get food into
the desert through like stratospheric
drone delivery or something like that as
long as people don't need to take
it's going to be interesting in 50 years
i don't know if it's going to be a civil
war or it's going to be a world war 3.
but it's looking like it's going to be a
world war 3 and then the u.s just
crumples and then it's going to be and
then i mean you look at world war one
you had the russian revolution right so
we could be looking at something like
that
yeah and the russians pulled out of the
war after the communists took over they
were like communists were like we're
anti-war that was a big part of their
thing so they killed a bunch of people
took the country and and basically
screwed the the al the the what are they
called the untaunt the no the on top was
the germans and the austrians the uh
central powers the central powers of
options deontant was the british allied
forces yeah and the italians and uh
after russia pulled out like screw them
over they were like well there goes our
ally right that's everything but then
the americans came in and
remember when trump millions said what
were even involved in world war one
anyway and then they made fun of him
yeah right um
we were talking we had michael malassan
and he made the same point he was like
yeah no we shouldn't have been it was
woodrow wilson was this disaster of a
president wasn't he the federal reserve
president yeah he signed the federal
reserve act he did sign the the act i
don't i don't know if he was ever the
president but yeah of of of the fed but
no no i'm not saying
right he was the president at the time
of the federal correct that's right
that's what i meant sorry right sorry
yeah yeah no i mean when i said of the
federal reserve i meant like that was
something that was
you know from the federal right yeah
yeah it grew from him yes right right
absolutely yeah what is it he's like the
worst president we've ever had he even
acknowledged that was the biggest
mistake or one that he ever made have
you heard that speech where he talks
about that he unwittingly gave control
of the united states to a bunch of
bureaucracies
i didn't realize no really he did a lot
he did a lot of bad things though
he did a lot of bad things he's a bad
guy and and a bad guy and you know the
espionage act and
restrictions on curtailments on civil
liberties during the war did he do the
fbi
uh no i don't me i i don't know i i
don't know who
was responsible for the fbi but um no
those later i think edgar hoover was in
the 20s maybe was it
1908 oh wow yep
so but i don't think teddy roosevelt
yeah that wasn't wilson then
but wilson was
wilson was a progressive
and um he
[Music]
a and and our entry into world war one
really and i think you can argue
created a
chain reaction and
and and did not serve our interest or
really the world's interest in many ways
it was theodore roosevelt he did the fbi
teddy what about the cia
the cia
i wonder if that was later was that yeah
40s that's my guess that was like cold
war stuff right right 1947.
yeah so who was 1947 truman yeah yep
there it is right there truman
yep wow man we look back all this stuff
and we're just like what a big mistake
and now uh we just keep chucking along
did you hear that things keep happening
that eisenhower speech when he was
leaving office and was like well sorry
guys we created a military industrial
complex if you let it get out of control
it's going to take over but it was the
best it was the best we could do we had
no choice he was basically alluding to
that sorry it's the best we could do
just don't let it get out of hand
man i can only imagine being around in
like the late 40s
being involved in this stuff and just
thinking to yourself like
well
long-term destruction to this country is
underway
you know just sit back and live your
life while you can that's i wonder if
many of them were thinking that with all
the stuff they did
then you look at everything that we have
now and it's just spiraling is goodwill
acid you know people need to realize
something we we grew up in a golden age
all these millennials you know marry you
especially golden age
as bad as everything's been like we've
had a recession we've had covet and
everything but like
the 80s to the early to like the 20 like
beginning of 2010 or whatever
it was
in the united states
i understand 911 i'm not trying to
downplay that but for a lot of us it was
just like air conditioning fast food
fast cars
the 90s especially
we didn't you know most people grew up
in a world where it was like when i'm
reading about world war one i'm like
holy
right like while all this stuff is going
on they're like the americans are like
we don't want war there's like pancho
via expansionism
there's there's northern ireland all of
these conflicts happening everywhere
people just blowing each other up and
then we grow up in this area where it's
like the united states
in in bubbled itself
and we are just like
what are we complaining about
i was gonna say you had the spanish flu
too i think that was in 1918 yeah right
that killed millions of people so yeah
the watching that footage from the world
from the they shall not grow older like
you see how flimsy the human body is
what we think of as we're protected and
all that crap like man just do what you
provoke it over there you're provoking
it everywhere i got this quote from
woodrow wilson this is after he signed
the federal reserve act uh he said i'm
the most unhappy man i've unwittingly
ruined my country a great industrial
nation is controlled by its system of
credit our system of credit is
concentrated the growth of the nation
therefore and all our activities are in
the hands of a few men we've come to be
one of the worst ruled one of the most
completely controlled and dominated
governments in the civilized world no
longer a government by free opinion no
longer government by conviction and the
vote of the majority but a government by
the opinion and duress of a small group
of dominant men
wow but he signed the stupid thing and
then he he was like look what i did i
don't know why he signed that
normally
i would uh well we are going to go to
super chats but i have bad news youtube
crashed on us and wiped out most oh i've
got all the super chats from before like
9 10.
so we'll just read as many as we can
that came after that but my apologies i
if youtube
breaks i don't know man
but uh would you kindly smash that like
button if you haven't already subscribe
to this channel and share the show if
you do like it head over to timcast.com
we are going to have a members only
segment coming up for you and we're
going to be talking about vaccine
mandates and social media policies
pertaining to that advocacy etc and that
will be at timcast.com and it's going to
be particularly interesting we save the
spicier stuff sometimes sometimes we
have to unfortunately but let's read
some of your super chats
all right
steve hauser says ha tim you just
admitted that conservatives do stuff i
gotcha although i'll keep doing what you
want and need by the way there will be
no nuclear war self-preservation is a
major factor self-pric self-preservation
is the factor as to why i think there
may be
because russia is going to russia is
looking at nato expanding all around it
now finland latvia is i think estonia no
no no latvia what are the countries on
the board is it estonia
it might be they donations that are on
the border with russia already so now
you got finland
above the map yeah this i'm on brave so
the the map doesn't have google maps
well anyway you get the point russia is
going to say in order to preserve
ourselves it's now or never
so that's my fear
all right
sunny z says hey tim i attempted to
purchase a subscription on your site via
parallel economy would not let me kept
timing out on the final step tried
firefox chrome and edge stripe worked
fine
sorry to hear it we'll we'll we're
always taking a look at it i got to tell
you guys you know we're we're a bit
scrappy we have like 30 employees and
we're trying to create a subscription
service and build shows and do all this
stuff so these are the early days try to
do with a different browser too he did
he said he tried a bunch of multiple
browsers yeah clearly cache i see
control f5 maybe um
yeah so this is this is why we also do
have stripe uh stripe isn't perfect but
they've done a substantially better job
than paypal locals uses stripe which is
rumble basically so we're cool with
stripe for uh for the most part but
you know i got no issue with them and um
their ceo has actually been responsive
to issues so i i think they're better
way better than paypal
but parallel economy is what we're
actually excited to promote and and and
be a part of because this is something
new that's definitively anti-censorship
you were saying on the border of russia
and the north of finland then estonia
latvia and belarus yep lithuania's
further and then there was concern about
ukraine
but ukraine had lot to do with gas uh
natural gas and gazprom but finland
now you got another nato country on
their border yo they're not happy about
this is
yeah man
stuff
all right let's see let's grab some more
super chits
let's see gad says why nancy pelosi
she's the speaker not a diplomat
i don't know i think the body
administration said nancy shouldn't go
right is that what happened oh i don't
know yeah they warned her about about
going maybe she was just oh i there was
a story the other day that paul pelosi
sold off at a loss a bunch of nvidia
stocks yeah 300 000 loss 365 thousand
dollar loss like one for every day of
the year some some people said it was
just tax loss harvesting yeah i was
thinking that that crossed my mind they
wanted to write off a loss on their on
their yearly earnings so that they go
under some sort of tax bracket
well i mean
it's just harvesting a loss so you can
be like i'm gonna keep the stock anyway
so he might buy back in or whatever i
don't know exactly how it works but uh i
just think it's really funny timing
you know with taiwan and the tsmc
and the chips bill
yeah
particularly convenient
how is it that you so many people go to
washington and make 175 000 a year in
congress and create generational wealth
yeah it's amazing isn't it like it is an
interesting question isn't it like more
than half of congress is our
millionaires
maybe i don't know something like that
quad foo says please invite mike glover
on the show he is the founder of
american contingency whose logo appears
on the leaked fbi docs about mve he is
getting
he is getting legal together for a
potential defamation suit
interesting do you guys see that ted
cruz smack down uh rey from the fbi
negative i think i did see project
veritas released this from a
whistleblower that the fbi considers
symbols of american history to be
extremist symbols like the betsy ross
flag
and one of the symbols they list is
called the gonzales flag you guys know
what that is no it's a it's a cannon
artillery and it says come and take it
the story is
actually really funny the history of the
gonzalez like texas and it was the
colony i think of gonzalez i think it
was a colony and they requested
defense and they were given one
old brass cannon
and so that's what they had and then the
mexican colonels or whatever commanders
came over and said turn over your cannon
and they made a flag with the cannon not
saying come and take it it's like this
one cannon and they're like tawar
so uh the funny thing is when ted cruz
was like
questioning like why the betsy ross flag
is on there he pulls off his own boot
and slaps on the table because his boot
has the gonzalez flag on it he's from
texas
i thought that was amazing
yep and then he mentions that this this
militia extremism doesn't include any
antifa or any leftist stuff on it or
cartels let's be honest yeah their lack
of uh
of of what you call it i guess
leadership on the cartel management is
is concerning the gadsden flag was on it
and he paused here's a license plate
from virginia and he's like so all the
people who have virginia license plates
you see i see them everywhere over here
because we're
we're on the border with virginia yep
they're all extremists he didn't have an
answer it's just insane the doj has been
weaponized completely
they've lost it
all right chris dobler says back off
china japan has godzilla
all right
that's right
all right let's see top gundy says
several infants were left to die after
being born alive during botched
abortions in minnesota in 2021 wow said
they sent the sent lydia the links on
twitter
terrible crazy terrible
raymond g stanley jr says adrian says
it's time for nationalism i agree i
agree
all right grace fang wants to challenge
ian he says ian you have an ignorant
view of christianity you are taking your
own personal experiences and nitpicky
bias over the littlest thing nothing is
perfect everyone and everything has
fault
i can't i can't deny that what you said
was true well all right
andrew hobson says taiwan is not nor has
it ever been a territory of china or as
the real ones call it west taiwan
agreed taiwan is the actual china
and the ccp took over the mainland and
they are an occupying force and i am not
a fan yeah the republic of china
is uh what is 170 islands taiwan's about
98 of the land mass of their country
yeah i'm completely in favor of
unification
of
taiwan with west taiwan
it's a good idea yeah i mean that would
be a way it would be way better for
everybody imagine what would happen to
the ccp like to the people of china if
the ccp was was removed and it was like
dude china is amazing man as a country
the p the history yeah and the land like
the geography is incredible too the the
history dude of the temples in the west
like in the mountains
in shu
i want to go yeah interesting man of
culture says the internment of japanese
ethnics happened because of the
ni'iahu incident where a japanese couple
tried to help a downed enemy pilot
escape hawaii
interesting
tyler w says if it makes anyone feel
better for taiwan china is going to
destabilize demographically politically
and economically in the next decade or
so
you know that's not a good thing
a country that's facing a collapse is a
desperate country and war shores up
resources so like
think of the united states and the
culture war and food shortages
military-industrial complex
the reason one of the reasons they say
that the u.s economy did so well after
world war ii was that we blew up all of
the competition
after the war if you wanted autos for
instance it was the u.s building and
exporting and these other industries and
germany and japan were wiped out
we will see
we will see you
tion
walmaran says china buying farmland and
distracting the us with a taiwan war so
russia can take ukraine to control
fertilizer it's a bait and switch tactic
to ensure we will live under communist
rule
well it's coming man yeah i just saw
blackrock partnered with coinbase that's
another concern yeah
mike derusha says youtube is making it
making it effing impossible for me to
send a super chat this is my seventh
attempt
i've been hearing that people have been
saying for some reason their superchats
are getting blocked they're not able to
post them so i don't know why
but uh
it must be just an accident
right just just a mistake a coding error
yeah maybe the things you're typing in
our taboo on the system or something i
had a video i think it was about
trans children or something and when it
went up it was getting no views and then
it had no audio on it
on my end when i played it it was
perfect when other people played it
there was no audio and some people
didn't even see it
and so then uh you know our social media
manager here dain he was like
there's no sound what happened and i was
like my files totally fine so i had to
re-upload and then delete it
very weird and they always just say it
must be a mistake and i'm like how does
a mistake like that happen come on
doesn't happen to jimmy kimmel does it
all right let's grab some more sparky
says nato started war putin's an
anti-globalist hero i absolutely 100
100 disagree i see putin as despotic
i'm not a fan of what russia is doing
but i'm also not so blind to just act
like nato's expansion isn't a
provocation
i don't i think i do not believe that
putin is a good dude at all he is not a
good dude
all right
ola
i don't know how to pronounce this
soberg
says turkey erdogan is still against
sweden and finland joining nato all
member states must agree what are putin
and erdogan talking about you think
i mean that'd be crazy if turkey breaks
off and sides with russia
man things will get crazy real quick
all right jonathan harris says question
for james as a fellow nc resident why do
you think we can't even pass medicinal
marijuana
uh when i can drive up to drive up north
to va and buy legally
i you know i i that's a good question i
think there i i know there was a renewed
effort in the general assembly to try to
get something done
on medical marijuana um and uh you know
i think there are
it's a divisive issue for uh
north carolina republicans as to
uh you know the legalization of any any
marijuana any liberalization of those
laws so um
you know maybe it's a generational thing
i think there are people in at least the
north carolina senate that are trying to
move the ball forward on that issue but
you know you raise a legitimate question
it doesn't make in turn it's not
internally consistent right that you
could go
to the va and get it but you can't go
elsewhere it just doesn't make sense but
there are a lot of things
that we labor under on a daily basis
that are inconsistent like we saw of
course in the coveted lockdowns right uh
that that don't make sense yet yet are
so hopefully something good will happen
in that regard tyrant's hunter says tim
look at the venezuela war games this
month china and russia are being given
the ability to build bases there
yep
that sounds
interesting
well
all right
paulie bruce says peace will inevitably
inevitably come soon when the sun micro
nova the magnetic shield flips and the
crust displaces again
invite ben davidson from suspicious
observer on youtube channel before it's
too late
you know what i'm really excited about
so we have uh tales from the inverted
world hosted by shane cashman and we're
launching a new show the inverted world
podcast which is specifically a
conversational show taking calls but i
also would love to see shane sit down
with all of these uh different
conspiracy theory people conspiracy
there's not the right word for it like
mudflood for instance right you know
that is yeah yeah the idea that a lot of
civilization's been covered in with mud
like there was one great civilization
and then there was a great flood and it
buried all of these buildings in mud and
that would have been recent too which is
the weird thing yeah because it's like
modern buildings well no they're modern
buildings because we think they're
modern oh interesting that's what the
theory is anyway it's not a conspiracy
this this theory it's like weird
alternate history stuff so
i'm really interested to see if uh if we
can incorporate that stuff too like
get some flat earther to try and explain
what they think and then you know have a
conversation with people who who think
these weird things
you know love it yeah there was a funny
graphic i commented on earlier it was
the sun tabloid showing a map of the
world and china was firing missiles to
the us and the us fire missiles back but
it was just like
it was the the typical like british
style projection of earth so
as a flat 2d picture it shows china
firing to the west it's like yo china
would if if it was a globe fire to the
east but more importantly fire to the
north because it would go
because the earth is around it's going
to go over the north pole before hitting
the u.s it also fires straight down from
right above us you know that can happen
too so keep that in mind when i flew
from new york to hong kong we went we
went over the north pole
and then like that's the shortest
distance right so that's what you do
but they drew this picture it was
actually really funny
all right
let's grab some super jits brandon
bryant says hasn't putin already offered
a line to the u.s when he first came
into power and the us rejected and
basically disrespected them is that true
i didn't know that that's what it felt
like in the late
2013 i mean he he wouldn't do interviews
and be like
i try to have diplomacy with these
people and they won't talk and now
they're using massive propaganda against
russia
triton 54 says ian is correct a single
ohio-class submarine ssgn can fire
hundreds of conventional tomahawks and
destroy every warship participating in
these exercises
more chicken ian oh holler yeah but
submarines are crazy yeah you ever ever
been on one no you guys ever been on a
submarine
20 000 leagues under the sea at disney
world maybe i think that's it i got to
there was a i can't remember where i was
but you pay 20 bucks and they let you go
on to a submarine okay like you just
walk up go down that sounds miserable oh
my gosh the worst thing ever it was so
cramped and i'm like people lived here
and they were like yeah and i think like
when they i can't remember the number
they gave me but i was like
that's even crazier okay it's already
cramped like they're there for two
months at a time or something wow yeah
that's so crazy
you know i imagine being in that in in
the middle of a war too right
never never might be the safest place to
be i guess yeah maybe yeah you're like
no one knows where i am
you know i'll just be safely hiding
under the water
barrett hodges says britain did not get
involved until belgium was invaded by
germany in world war one
belgium belgium yeah the tripwire cliff
lord says ian check out benny willis
wills poem who is they on youtube
there's a song by the singer gem called
they and it's really funny because
there's a bunch of like
you know um hate speech research
researchers who claim the word they is
anti-semitic and it references the jews
specifically
and so then whenever this song from
whenever i put on like pandora or
something and the song comes on
it's called they and she says like who
made up all the rules we follow them
like fools and then i'm like based on
the context from the anti-defamation
league this lady is very anti-semitic
like everything she's saying but of
course
they could be anybody well that's what
they do the i'm referring specifically
in they i'm referring to like the hate
speech researchers not any class of
people they anything you say they're
like that what you say
that's actually anti-semitic and you're
like okay what like when alex jones was
saying globalist they came out and
claimed globalist was an anti-semitic
slur and i'm like alex jones not talking
about jewish people are you talking
about he's probably more likely to be
talking about lizard people than jewish
people but that's what they do
that's how they get you the consultant
class is they yeah the consultant
all right catman says got triggered last
night when you denied my existence lol
catman was a dc character at one point
catman didn't you claim there was no cat
i thought there was no cat man you were
wrong catwoman
i didn't know there was a cat man
raymond g stanley jr says tim i watched
kill all others again recently y'all
should too
it's the google yellow to white change
we will be the others unless we are not
have you guys seen this what show was
that
what that was on
you want to look at that look that up
kill all others others yeah isn't it
like you're not an other i think uh
electric dreams yes
yo this is a you should watch it okay
everyone everyone listening right now
you should watch electric dreams i mean
the whole this comes from the hanging
stranger a short story by philip k dick
yep so electric dreams is philip k
dick's stories
the whole show is good the whole sierra
like electric dreams it's like a bunch
it's it's it's philip k dick's stories
but the kill all other stories like
basically this one this guy one day is
watching tv and a politician says that
they want to kill all others and then
he's like what and then when he goes to
work nobody cares and and he's like did
you see what they said and they were
like no you're mistaken and he's like no
they really said there's like no that
couldn't have happened the crazy thing
about it is because of what you were
saying to me the other day ian where
you're like when you went and talked to
your parents
and said biden's crazy and your mom was
like no he's not then you come back a
month later she's like yeah actually but
that first response
when we had like uh richie mcginnis and
his mom on
and i mentioned that feminists are more
likely to be pro-war these days and she
was like no they aren't
it felt just like that like that show
what they're portraying that when this
politician said they wanted to kill all
others he goes to work and they're like
no i don't know what you're talking
about i didn't see that that's crazy
that never happened and he's like i
watched it how did you not watch it
and then he goes outside and there's
like a woman running screaming and
people are chasing after her and they
throw her down and he's like what are
you doing and they're like she's an
other and he's like leave her alone and
they go
what are you an other are you one of
them and he's like no no
and then like it's it's basically just a
show giving you a metaphor for
the others when people start blaming a
different faction someone else for their
problems it's a good show man you should
totally watch it for real
i'll have to check it out
vadir um sombra says so i have hundreds
of pounds of food many bags of sticks
with thousands of food pellets as we
approach potential world war three event
how do i explain express to those in
denial well i don't know if like look
i'll put it this way
jenna just tried to fire a bunch of
missiles over taiwan so i mean if you're
going to be a prepper now's really the
time to be a prepper i guess
they said a food shortage is coming i'm
not telling anybody to stock up on you
know beans or anything like that but if
a food shortage is coming and they keep
saying it they're screaming it
you know i'll put it this way
we talk about how
you know we say joe biden's crazy and
your mom doesn't see it yeah mentally
deficient was i think
of your mom the weird thing is i told
her that like five months ago and she
was like yeah yeah i know which i get it
i get it then i saw her again and she
was like no he's not he's fine then i
saw her the third time she's like yeah
yeah i get it i'm like what is happening
how can someone go in and out of this
like you wanna i guess she wants to like
him i think that's the problem yeah
i don't know man i'll just tell you
there's a lot of people who aren't
paying attention
and so when you say something like i
just bought some emergency food they
laughed they're like what are you
talking about you're crazy and then
you're like well that's a self-soothing
thing yeah to say that preppers are
crazy yeah preppers are laughing you
know like
they could china could literally launch
an icbm and they'd be sitting in their
rocking chair with their shotgun being
like i'm good
i know what's up i don't care
so it's kind of like what do you have to
lose by prepping
did did preppers lose out on anything
that i know of hunting and farming and
you know foraging and storing up food
and just living
and then everyone's laughing at them and
they're like i don't care
like they're not being hurt at all by
prepping at all
yeah i would say don't don't like
publicize your your prep because you
become a target to people that don't
have anything that's that's probably the
worst thing that could happen from a
vocal prepper
yeah
but in the event something does happen
they're going to be like okay i'm good
everyone else will be screaming it'll be
like there'll be zombie apocalypse in
new york what do you think what do you
think
2.5 million people in manhattan island
are going to do in three days when
there's no food left
yeah create new types of food
create new types of food eat each other
eat fish they'll go fishing is what i
meant
the gowanus canal
sludge
yeah the people who will start it's
gonna be like fallout but not because of
nuclear wars because they're gonna start
eating fish from the hudson and then
their skin's gonna start falling off
remember that tick tock of that girl
that jumped in the hudson river with the
statue of liberty in the
in the no
she like i guess she wasn't from new
york but she she jumped in the water i
think she ended up being fine though
yeah you just you ended up being sick it
would have been fun if she jumped out
she was like ah and her skin's like
melting it's like the guy from indiana
jones when they open the ark of the
company
is it just like a a human waste dump and
a chemical dump or something the river
it's just filthy it's a city it's
there's tons of waste
i would tell you guys a story it's been
a long time so i could be getting this
wrong just taking consideration but i
was when i was working for this
environmental nonprofit they said
they went to lake the beach lake
michigan beach in chicago
and they asked everyone to do a survey
everybody filled out a survey and gave
their information they said we're going
to call you back in a couple days
they then called everybody back and
asked them
uh if they had gotten sick
and
what kind of sickness they got
and it was something like 90 percent of
people who went into lake michigan got
diarrhea within the next day
oh like they got sick from something
they probably ingested some of the water
the water's filthy because all that crap
from all the cities around lake michigan
funnels down into chicago and then
everyone swims in it
yeah yup that's chicago
gotta love it
i always had this this uh fake
conspiracy theory that on st patrick's
day when they dye the river green
they're just finding a way to secretly
get rid of toxic waste like yeah we're
dying the river greens
pouring sludge and industrial waste into
the river then everyone's like yay
no they're just dying green it's so
weird that they dye the river green with
algae or something i don't think some
natural
way i don't know i don't know maybe
maybe maybe my fake conspiracy is a real
conspiracy people actually think it or
something
all right ken says no offense to your
sponsors but also being low carb what
plans do you make for emergency food or
would you go full 1700s and switch to
easier to store grains etc avoid turkeys
they're mean
um
yo if the apocalypse happened i'll eat
tree bark like i'll eat what i have to
eat you can eat leaves i was working one
day and i saw a deer eating leaves and
then i looked up can you eat leaves and
you can you can eat them they you know
we eat we eat a lot of leaves you know
spinach yes
romaine
all the good stuff but uh i was reading
like what you're supposed to do and this
thing online said
you rip the leaf and then rub it on your
skin and then wait 15 minutes and if
there's no reaction then you rip a leaf
and then you rub it on your mouth and
then you wait and if there's no reaction
then you take a small piece and you eat
it and you wait and there's no reaction
then you eat a little bit more and then
after a few days of slowly increasing
you'll find out if you're safe to eat
certainly probably everyone should do
that if there's a group of people
one person doing it isn't enough because
someone might have an allergy same thing
with berries not look don't take advice
from me i'm just saying i read something
online i don't know if it's true but
they would say like you take like a
fruit and you rub it on your skin to see
if it causes some kind of reaction or
toxin or something like that
but also out here we got uh wine berry
season ended we got paw paw season
coming up i'm really excited for that
there's just there's it's just like
infinite food you go outside and they're
just raining paw paws down on your head
and they're they're hitting you
and uh they're delicious
i'm reading about the chicago river
getting dyed it says it's more or less
food coloring i don't know what that
means why would they do
more or less
that's so wild i wonder what they diet
with i gotta know remember when dave
matthews band's bus driver released all
the sewage onto that boat yeah on top of
somebody it's a chicago legend they were
driving over the bridge and then the bus
driver just pressed like the blackwater
release
because the bridge is graded and they
thought they'd get away with it and then
there was a boat like a wedding party
right underneath and all got sprayed
yeah
the legend of the dave matthews band
i don't want to say what it's called but
we'll call it the ish shower
those are the days man
all right
yeah man
sheldon france says submarine submariner
here our ssbns have the capacity to
carry enough nuclear warheads to blow up
a majority of the world we have 14 of
them
i don't know why that's not a good thing
but what do you do when everyone else is
doing it man
mike de russia says greens in a salad
are dandelion leaves
greens
what do you mean greens like collard
greens or what
i think just that the greens in the set
it's a strange step i think the sentence
fragment was improperly typed but it's
quote greens end quote in a salad
i don't know is that like what spring
mix or something i don't know what
you're talking about i know you can eat
dandelion i don't know that dandelion is
not native to here we brought it here
because it was medicinal and then i
started watching all these videos of
these mountain hillbillies doing that
they do the the deep fried dandelion
it's like an appalachian
yeah i'm excited to try it we just don't
have any dandelions right now all right
last i'm going to say on the chicago
river getting dye green they do it with
60 pounds of dye
and it's top secret formula that they
call leprechaun dust someone commented
that it was like a totally safe
plant-based food day mm-hmm then it must
be true
i hope it is your god how could you do
that to your your fish pot when did this
when did they start doing it
i don't know 60 60s no no no some guy
had a big factory and he's like what am
i going to do with all this industrial
waste yeah 1962. orange when it's in
power just dump it in the river it's
orange when when it's dry and then oh
where
i don't know
all right my friends if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and
share the show with your friends
head over to timcast.com become a member
support parallel economy that's what we
use for our financial transactions so we
can start building this ecosystem but
we're going to have an uncensored tim
cast irl episode with those go up monday
through thursday at 11 p.m so we'll have
that for you you can follow the show at
tim cast irl you can follow me
personally at tim cast james you want to
shout anything out yeah uh you can
follow me at j lawrence l a w
l-a-w-r-e-n-c-e-n-c
on twitter envisage.law is my law firm's
website right on
you can find me on instagram or wechat
at closer kitty and i demand that you
subscribe to pop culture crisis on
youtube we go live at 3 p.m eastern noon
pacific time every monday through friday
uh go subscribe join us over there we
have fun and i'll see you on the after
show i'm going to be oh
it's like 100 times more fun than this
show because like everything here is
like the world's ending it's a wild ride
i'll be honest
we literally party yeah and then pop
culture crisis is like you see that new
movie
hanging out money's flying through the
air and it's like wash away all of your
pains i'll be on pop culture crisis
tomorrow at 3 p.m yes looking forward to
seeing you there uh last like i said the
last last thing i'm going to say about
the chicago river apparently some
plumbers spilled green dye into the
water mayor daley senior saw it and want
to know if they could do it again for st
patrick's day maybe they used a
different dye hey follow me at ian
crossland.net get through my social
medias you can follow me all over the
place i'll see you guys later
hey i talk way more on the members
podcast
we'll see you all over at timcast.com
thanks for hanging out
you